Thank you Madonna ragazzi Sono gasato va
bene Questo è il videogioco Oh madonna
come sono contento Salve a tutti ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video io sono Favij e
oggi siamo su Resident Evil che è il
miglior Resident Evil per me cioè vi
avevo detto dopo la demo che avrei
portato il gioco completo e ci siamo
vamos sono
gasatissimo e penso che sia il momento
che aspettavo da una vita
Beh è partito bene Comunque vedo
galline
al fascicolo minchia
Ma questa è ashly questa è la fiera del
presidente Raga ma che succede
Ma cosa
Ma scusa allora io l'avevo giocato tanto
tempo fa ma sta parte Non me la
ricordavo io 30 settembre 1998 quando il
poliziotto in me morì quella notte era
con City fu Rasa al suolo a causa delle
armi biologiche della Umbrella
Io sono sopravvissuto ma per molti altri
non è stato così
mi è stato chiesto di unirmi a un
programma governativo Top Secret
non che avessi scelta questa stessa
parte della demo comunque
e quelle missioni mi hanno quasi ucciso
ma almeno mi hanno aiutato a non pensare
ad avere
quella notte
[Musica]
anche solo per un secondo
stavolta può essere diverso
deve esserlo ma più o meno conoscendo
come va a finire ripeto io l'ho giocato
un po' di tempo fa Raga non me lo
ricordo tutto Infatti sti inizio non me
lo ricordavo per niente
Questa è la finale del presidente Ashley
come ci sei finito
il messaggio che si trova
19 che cerco qualcuno
sarà qualcuno di molto importante vero
il capo ci ha dato ordini precisi
aiutatelo ha detto Beh di sicuro non
sarete qui per arrostire marshmallow
O forse sì
strano senso dell'umorismo
Ti confesso un piccolo segreto resti fra
noi
un sacco di gente è scomparsa qui
intorno vediamo un po' che questa cosa
vada e loro vanno tranquilli come niente
fosse Vabbè quindi
ormai dovreste essere abituati No vabbè
La settimana scorsa sono spariti degli
escursionisti
sono sicuro che mi aiuterete
e ridono Ma che cazzo ridi che ti stai
per schiantare da un minuto all'altro
cioè
io non ho capito ma anche nei telefilm
la gente che va quell'altro giorno è
sparita mia cugina e vabbè ma allora non
ci andare Non ho capito
che ci siamo vabbè
[Applauso]
la natura Chiama Torno subito e vai a
cagare Comunque io qua Eh già a me Io
avrei rubato il van me ne sarei andato
il van gif che cazzo
sto vedendo ragazzi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sigaretta
E comunque allegro eh Chissà In che
posto della Spagna precisamente ma lo
sono sempre chiesto in che posto
[Musica]
gli escursionisti di prima che deve
essere
Madonna per il poliziotto più [__]
io non ho mai visto si può essere ah ah
no way lui è andato proprio ha fatto il
percorso che si fa che dovrò farmi io
adesso quello che c'era nella demo
quindi era lui quello che avevamo
bruciato sulla sulla croce di legno
è caduto dentro
forse sarebbe meglio se andassi a dare
un'occhiata parli di Meo e di te vado io
Eh figurati
Arrivederci fratello Io guardo la
macchina non voglio una multa per
divieto di sosta
grazie per l'aiuto Sicuramente sta
passando di Napoli per farti la multa
certo pieno di polizia municipale qua
Comunque a parte che lui la polizia
quindi Ma di che
c'è la polizia può fare la multa alla
polizia Vabbè comunque Oh Bella lì Beh
allora e quindi quello che è stato
bruciato sulla sulla croce nella demo
che trampoli era l'ufficio di polizia Ah
bene bene bene bene questa parte qui la
conosciamo bello Comunque vabbè per chi
non ha visto la demo mi rifaccio tutto
tranquillamente Allora casuali vediamo
di fare meno figure de merda del solito
perché questo videogioco è talmente
importante
che morirò prima di finirlo ed è anche
parecchio difficile Secondo me mi giusti
Vedo già le mani avanti per quando farò
cagare Ok Me lo metto le mani avanti
Quello è importante per me so sono
quello che non si fa i cazzi suoi Mai
mai Voi siete pronti siete pronti Ah e
quindi lo stemma che troviamo adesso per
terra e dello zio
ok
giorno
nonno Ciak
cos'è che dice scusa
che comunque Ragazzi ma che cacchio sta
cucinando sto tizio
Sì sì guardati in giro Non ti far
domande io uscì sarei uscito corre
buttandomi di testa dalla finestra fa
niente Mario Fernandez Castagno proprio
lui quello che doveva pisciare occhio
canzone in bocca eh
Madonna ragazzi ogni volta che vedo sta
scena mi spacca cioè Incredibile anche
lui l'ha spaccato Secondo me
Ah questo è Carlos castagno
Grazie della chiave fratello voglio
sempre vedere che cosa sta cucinando
perché il dado Star Che schifo no no non
è vero è solo cucina diversa impariamo a
non esprimere sempre il nostro giudizio
sulle cose che fanno gli altri eh
ragazzi che qua è importante Oh
E se va nella cantina
bellissimo Allora ragazzi importante io
non so e questa cosa non l'ho capita se
il remake è stato fatto esattamente
uguale a quello originale
stavolta non lo non gli sparo al topo
perché tanto non mi dà niente
perché anche l'inizio che c'era Ashley
che stava che la figlia del Presidente
che stava morendo Cioè l'hanno
teoricamente l'hanno accettata
nel gruppo dico
Non me la ricordavo io quella scena
quindi forse hanno aggiunto delle cose
forse è diverso dal 4 c'è qualcosa in
più
Carlos castagno
Questo è quello che è andata a pisciare
Questo è quello della macchina
Qual è la situazione
questo quello che era rimasto in
macchina questo che sta parlando del
coso credo eh
torniamo alla macchina va bene E sì
quindi non ho ben capito se è diverso eh
vedremo comunque perché io il 4 più o
meno me lo ricordo l'ho giocato così
tanto tempo fa sono stato un paio 2-3
anni perché me lo rigiocato
giorno bella la mia solita Mira del
cazzo
e appena di morire però che cazzo
minchia oh è riuscito sia qua che nella
demo a beccarmi sto qua oh non riesco a
farlo fuori Madonna è l'unico zombie di
tutto il sentiero 4 che non va giù Cioè
che cazzo gli devo tirare a questo qua
per farlo fuori Minchia mi hai caduto
colpire per forza poi me levato anche un
po' Eh guarda sti stronzi minchia questi
qua li fai fuori Come niente eh
vabbè ma lasciamolo lì ragazzi ma non ho
capito Cioè questo deve scassare le
porte come se fossero sue
va bene
Minchia Lion Comunque tu sei Sei
veramente la persona più sfigata del
pianeta dove minchia Vai succede
qualcosa
hanno rapito la figlia del Presidente
questo l'avete capito Vabbè è lui è qua
per ritrovarla Per cercarla perché ha
avuto una segnalazione che si trova qua
in Spagna poi cioè ma vabbè
qui quando uno
la figlia del Presidente
si trova in questo villaggio
come pensavamo quindi ben fatto
mi serve la posizione di un lago forse
si trova lì ricevuto Mi metto alla
ricerca
La gente qui è impazzita
la mia scorta è
prevedo un pelato che entra dalla porta
Eccolo qua
la invidi la chioma di Leon
sai su Tinder Come va la faccio dove mi
faccio Tinder con le foto di Lyon Voglio
vedere che succede
Grazie raga ottima accoglienza
TripAdvisor 10 su 10 poi gli fa male
sempre la spalla destra sto cristiano
non ho mai capito perché solo quella
destra cioè se posso mi ficcano cartoni
in bocca e accettate nella coscia però
gli fa male la spalla destra sta roba
Non si capisce ma chi se ne frega Allora
quanti colpi ho cinque ma mi ha qualcosa
c'ho io nel menu Scusate ho una cura
fine va bene una cura e tutto ciò con
cui siamo andati a recuperare la via del
presidente no
quello lo dovevo fare fuori ragazzi ci
aveva la polvere da sparo su Strunz me
lo ricordavo i corvi vanno fatti fuori a
quanto pare danno proiettili non so come
ce l'hanno la polvere da sparo per fare
i proiettili allora
e qua teoricamente il salvataggio
dovrebbe funzionare Eccolo qua
salvataggio deposito ha Personalizza
valigetta attenzione va bene Questo lo
vedremo più avanti ragazzi Beh beh sta
roba qua Non me la ricordavo Eh secondo
me è tutta roba nuova ma neanche negli
altri remake mi pare che ci fosse
Vabbè vediamo Let's go Allora ehm qua
tutto scassato
adesso mi fotte Ah che uno Eccolo lì
vedi che mi ha droppato qualcosa sto
stronzo Allora vediamo se riesco Ah qua
c'è qualcosa Aspetta non mi scusi che
c'è qua
Ah le pesce e tasse Le pesetas sono
utilizzati sono i soldi utilizzati per
trainare con il Mercante quello che fa
welcome
logorroico sarai tu Testa di cazzo aiuto
perchè c'ho una Mira di merda Allora
ragazzi Questo gioco vanno utilizzati
cioè i proiettili vanno risparmiati se
io non facessi schifo Madonna l'ho
ucciso mi sono senza dirgli anche il
calcio in bocca eh Lo sapevo che c'eri
tu dietro eh cosa facevate decespugli
sporcaccioni Minchia che cartoni in The
Face
e fino qua ma il coltello si rompe pian
piano che vedo che c'ha l'usura Beh il
coltello può rompersi Ma questa cosa Boh
e si può rompere un coltello eh comunque
strano perché se si rompe il coltello
Con cosa di picchio col pensiero Qua c'è
una trappola eh non è che la piglia
un'altra volta no non c'è più mi
ricordavo ci fosse una trappola vabbè
sono stronzo ah Dimmi sono stronzo c'è
scritto stronzo qua Non lo so Cioè era
più indietro mi sono fatto male
Guarda che qua c'è uno strunz a me vuole
[__] a Chist a me vuole [__] a chi
volevi mamma ragazzi il vostro Favij di
quartiere che
menay Village Non so come ma questa cosa
mi riesce abbastanza bene il Resident
Evil Allora erbetta rossa che si combina
con quella verde e quindi a Cure non
siamo messi male però mi servirebbe la
erbetta verde Allora ragazzi vediamoli
non fare cazzate visto che adesso
approcciamo il villaggio dove troviamo
il nostro amico poliziotto Eccolo qua
Carlos castagno
povero Carlos Castagno che non voleva
prenderla multa Ah no questo neanche
Questo è l'altro eh Mi dispiace era
meglio la multa dalla Municipale Però
noi guardiamo il gallo Il gallo che sta
urlando Mica lui
Va bene comunque molto allegro Sono
molto contento andiamo avanti Allora
vediamo di non fare stronzate e non vi
prometto niente perché dovrei provare ad
avere un approccio molto più Stealth
rispetto al solito però devo stare
attento perché questi
Qua c'è gente che fa la ronda la ronda
da sole
mi sporgo così vedo meglio eh ragazzi no
perché qua non vedo più la gente dov'era
Eccola qua Allora ragazzi Steel Mi
raccomando
mi raccomando vediamo di non far cacate
Gallo Stai zitto
è una l'abbiamo fatta fuori Vabbè e gli
anni di Assassin's Creed si vedono
stai zitta
Oh testa di cazzo Gallo Ma ti pare Vabbè
dai ci provo Let's go
perfetto Bravo Favij complimenti allora
vediamo se riesco a fare la cosa giusta
Eh io me la sono studiata così
Madonna ragazzi Veramente sono orborbo
Madonna e [__]
Ok allora non è andata malissimo Ho
sprecato un po' di proiettili ma ho dato
fuoco a tutto
Allora l'obiettivo ragazzi Questo
sopravvivere tanto avrò tempo per
prendere tutte le cose che ci sono in
giro anche dopo non è un problema
L'importante non farmi fregare da dietro
se arriva gente
e neanche prendere le lancette in faccia
se passo qua in mezzo riesco a passare
Beh uno l'ho fatto fuori comunque eh
anche due Cos'è sta roba qua Ho trovato
un uovo
grazie Va bene Adesso sì che è a posto
la situazione adesso ho vinto merda Io
volevo andare contro quello ok
Ho spagato la fontana Allora uno dos il
trash i quattro e questo non l'ho ucciso
Però allora
non sta andando malissimo Eh sta andando
meglio dell'altra volta ok
mamma sta parte di gioco è veramente
ansiolitica poi tra l'altro è pieno
zeppo di gente c'è un casino
Si sentono proprio del rotule che si
spaccano quando clicco un calcio Oh
salve non avevo visto sto coso Va bene
allora Proviamo a vedere se riesco a
trovare la granata frammentazione perché
mi serve qua
Ok salve Arrivederci
è arrivato lo zio che non credo possiamo
fare fuori tra l'altro Eh se bisogna
solo aspettare che finisca tutto sta
ambaradan Madonna che brutto che è
Arrivederci Madonna Raga grazie No
veramente non so dov'è il tizio con la
motosega non nella minima idea eh ok
giorno Scusatemi Arrivederci Oh
Ok ok va bene va bene Ho già capito cosa
devo fare va bene userò Questo è uno
strumentopolo
Porca [__] va bene la corrente è
servita tantissimo
anche a lui che non c'entra una sega Eh
non mi ricordo dov'è la granata
frammentazione ma ci servirebbe
tantissimo effettivamente perché Madonna
raga quanti cazzo sono ok ma non puoi
darlo lo stesso il calcio sarebbe
veramente utile lo sai zio ma forse qua
c'è qualcosa attenzione Uh bravo bravo
bravo Chiudi chiudi la porta chiudi la
porta
bravissimo bravissimo ok
Eh mi sa che sta portando non dura un
cazzo ragazzi va bene
e ci abbiamo provato ma niente pure
da sopra Madonna raga Che bordello e mi
lasciano in mezzo alla merda così
me la volete dare una cazzo di Granata
frammentazione Vi prego no volevo
suggerire sopra Forse era la finestra
Ah da sopra il tetto Minchia è contento
Non me lo ricordavo
questo qua che cazzo è
ok
Oh ma vuole finire sta roba è un'ora e
vado avanti
Minchia
la campana la campana l'ho sentita c'è
la campana Ciao Campana Fermi tutti time
out
Campana alla fine del primo tempo eh
tutti verso un tè caldo
è stata più ansiolitica Stavolta che la
demo guarda
Madonna
di
servir che serviva
Questa è la mia spagnola eh
a Lord Sadler
proprio lui
Todo poderoso sembra un po' esagerato
e anche la campana ci ha salvato il Kill
chiudi la porta va là prima che ci
ripensino magari si accorgono che sono
ancora lì Grazie ragazzi a prezzo con la
vostra simpatia e accoglienza
un calore umano calore che ha provato
soprattutto il poliziotto però va
Ma che cazzo succede qua
una roba del genere
Non me la ricordavo per niente però
vabbè
Wow
Madonna ragazzi Non vedevo l'ora Non
vedevo l'ora e siamo arrivati alla fine
della demo Quindi adesso sicuramente
riparte proprio così perché
evidentemente io ho lasciato Uh
ho trovato grazie
non c'è GPS tipo ricevuto minchia questo
è finito malissimo smartphone
Questa gente è pazza eh beh non sanno
paura mappa giornata va bene Ah si può
andare qua sopra
Vediamo cosa c'è ma io potevo salire qua
sopra anche prima sì Minchia sarebbe
stato stra utile Porca [__] Mi sono
cacato nelle mutande grazie Vabbè va
bene ragazzi direi che ci siamo e
possiamo proseguire questo c'è qua
dentro
ho trovato un Rubino raga sta roba si
vende un sacco di soldi questa Credo sia
la porta per andare avanti perché quella
dove sono entrati loro non mi va Dai
questa è dove era arrivato il tizio con
la motosega quindi promette benissimo
Raga non vedo l'ora entra qua dentro
Salve
c'è la mucca scusi io sento bordello
però non vedo nessuno mai ce la zia
piano piano Sì non ho capito se il
coltello prima o poi lo perderò perché
vedo che pian piano non scende la
l'usura Anzi forse adesso mi si rompe
proprio
No Ancora mi dura va bene iniziano i
pistole come fanno questi ad avere la
munizioni da pistola dentro il loro
corpo Scusatemi non hanno mai vista una
pistola si può entrare piano No è chiusa
Oh merda cazzo stai facendo questo
Ecco si è rotto il coltello Perfetto Va
bene proseguiamo per occhio ho fatto
fuori tutti quanti senza un criterio
cioè proprio li ho spaccato il culo Uh
c'è un tesoro là dietro attenzione come
ci si arriva dall'altra parte vabbè Eh
non ho idea Questo
c'è un'altra chiamata Ragazzi ma
incredibile Ci sono un sacco di robe
chiuse a chiave io come faccio a trovare
le chiavi di ste cose Cos'è questo Note
blu richiesta Puoi ricevere diversi
incarichi tramite le note Blu Ok Per
l'amor di Dio C'è qualcuno disposto a
liberarci dei medaglioni blu di compensa
tre Spinelli mi danno Ma come tre
Spinelli €5 dai due canne quindi Sì
posso fare fuori i medaglioni blu sono
queste secondarie Allora Uh ma qua c'è
una porta c'è una Portici bella comunque
sempre tutto allegro eh quindi
a tu a me vorresti [__] a me ne
dovete mangiare di pastasciutta anzi di
uova marroni dei vostri polli
Beh forse dovrei migliorare la mira ma
quello è un altro discorso
è esploso tutto Vabbè Volevo solo
passare comunque ce l'hanno i hanno le
armi quindi hanno un C4 comunque cos'era
quella c'hanno nella Uh pianta gialla
cosa fa la pianta gialla Scusami cioè
diventa unisci ripristina il triplo di
una salute di una pianta verde singola e
aumenta la salute massima acido Uras
Minchia ma questo è utilissimo la devo
usare adesso praticamente Quindi la la
pianta gialla mi aumenta la salute
massima Beh è utilissima sta roba
ragazzi Dobbiamo ricordarcelo eh questa
qua
l'unico personaggio che mi segue nei
ragionamenti incredibile
Ok poi devo passare Ah vedi che mi fa
passare di sopra Ah no mi fa andare dove
c'era il tesoro Ok scendi
che era qua No eccolo perfetto
cos'è Ah caraffa Ragazzi ho trovato un
sacco di roba se non hai appena vado
combinare puoi combinare i tesori sto
male quindi adesso io posso andare qua e
metterci il rubino che ho trovato prima
incastona gemme
No vabbè raga Sto malissimo e questo e
questi non li posso incastrare Vabbè
comunque valgono di più se incastonati e
vende roba qua è pazzesca raga pesetas
everywhere
Ok ho rotto
la Cioè lui rompe i lucchetti a Calci
Questo è un Dio praticamente non è un
uomo
Che cazzo c'è là fuori ragazzi Raga uh
c'è un altro Rubino Ecco mi sa che
questo lo dovevo incastonare una cosa ve
lo faccio adesso perché mi dimentico
Madonna ragazzi che cazzo c'è fuori
Scusatemi ma chi è
C'è un tizio Guarda io c'ho una granata
frammentazione qua coltello da cucina Ah
ho trovato la ruota dentata che mi serve
per dopo Porca [__] io salirei qua
Sali Sali veloce veloce veloce veloce
Non so cosa sia Non l'ho visto Beh beh
non so chi sia ma secondo me è meglio se
non mi tocca ecco Quello sicuramente
adesso a spaccare questo dovrei fare in
fretta che questo qua è veloce oh oh oh
quanto cazzo ci ha messo arrivare qua 0
secondi ragazzi
no Ma chi cazzo oh
avete notato che ha fatto il mio stesso
verso Scusatemi se per caso utilizzo
questa Granata frammentazione serve lo
chiedo per un amico vediamo posso usare
Oh merda
badante arriva arriva Oh bastardo eh
vabbè ma con una granata nel culo non è
morto quindi tu porca [__]
smorzo No non è morto e Vabbè ragazzi
non è che posso fa' tutto io qua eh oh
oh
Minchia raga come lo schivato non lo so
ma fa danno anche agli altri sto qua
perché sennò non gli sparo sto tizio
Madonna Vabbè ma raga cioè sto male
ma mi sembra un esagerazione Cioè ma chi
cazzo è Oh frate è già un problema Oh
chi cazzo è pure
Uno l'ho capito dai Veloce bravissimo
Non ce la farò mai a farlo fuori
Ho colpito quello sbagliato Scusate è
Mori Oh
Meno male che riesco a schivarlo
Forse dovrei stare eh decisamente zitto
uso questo Vediamo se funziona Sì mi ha
aumentato la salute massima figata se
fossi anche bravo a sparare sarebbe
ancora più utile Però vabbè con un altro
discorso tu potresti morire Non lo so
No ragazzi c'è il Terribile sta cosa
Come arrivano altri Basta che cazzo è
mojito no raga È incredibile Cioè
veramente sono troppi
Ma eravate in due prima che cazzo è
successo
Chi è Vabbè ma ragazzi è terribile
quanti cazzo di cosa gli ho tirato una
granata frammentazione nel culo cosa
devo fare
e muori cazzo no niente non muore
proprio in questa qua due ore
è morto è morto due ore
E vabbè ragazzi Minchia terribile
ok
Ho perso tutta ancora Basta che palle mi
fa fuori se non mi curo mi fa fuori
questa cosa è terrificante
Cioè mi sono dovuto curare cazzo guarda
quanto m'ha tolto Ma cos'è Oh
ma raga Ma oh Ma quanta cazzo di vita
avete Ma basta Non ho io una pistola
c'ho una [__] va M'hanno fatto
malissimo c'erano in 2000 erano Ma vi
sembra il modo vediamo se riesco a
mettere la ruota dentata che mi è
costata Oh tutto a che prezzo ragazzi
cioè madonna Oh
minchia tutto questo per aprire una
porta di merda Cioè io non ho parole
raga Veramente non ho paura questo è
morto ma si può No Gesù Madonna Eh
sarebbe stato più utile avere una
doppietta almeno quella Ma di qua c'è
un'altra fattoria Uh tutto scassato io
non so come sono messa a proiettile
sinceramente Ma dai un sacco di risorse
comunque Uh posso spostare il carro
Questa è una testa di mucca quello di
prima c'ha la testa di mucca comunque io
voglio capire cioè praticamente aveva si
è fatto una maschera col bestiame si va
di qua vamos non so dove sto andando
Raga non mi ricordo niente di Resident
Evil 4 cioè molto poco
L'importante è che non scenda roba
giorno mi scusi
[__] di merda
Ah vedi che se lo sapevo che
scendevatela qua teste di culo Io lo
sapevo Minchia Ditemi se non le so le
cose prima che succedono le so ormai io
io le so posso scavalcare lo stesso che
è successo posso farvi fuori nel dubbio
E vabbè che cazzo Sei un cecchino
oh
sono morti Vabbè potete andare Ah c'è la
stradina di fianco Scusate raga io vedo
Madonna cioè in equilibrio comunque
sembrava un po' il ponte dell'infamia
dita che ci scappa Oh
Nel dubbio ma nel dubbio
è viva ma nel dubbio incredibile
il 4 Oh
Allora non so bene dove sta andando ma
se utilizzassi la torcia Lyon non
sarebbe male ad esempio non vedo niente
niente ce l'aveva la torcia sto
cristiano una volta non c'è non la usi
più
Guarda che mamma ho mazzato Corvi per
molto meno eh ragazzi permesso Oh
finalmente un po' di gente che aveva un
po' che non la vedevo forse dalle piante
Ah qua ci sono le trappole attenzione
raga Eh perché secondo me se qua mi
corre addosso della
merda
Ok non mi ha preso non mi ha preso devo
riuscire a farlo saltare prima che mi
lancia un'altra Eh che palle
Ok a posto
Non è che posso fa sta vita qua Occhio
che se venite di qua c'è una trappola
Vabbè venite Vieni vieni vieni prego
prego avanti prego
Venga venga Eccolo qua è morto solo lui
va bene
chi chi sparo lui aspetta uno
io non ci credo quello gli ha fatto
protezione col corpo io voglio morire
morire
Vabbè allora se riusciamo a fare se
riusciamo a raccogliere un po' di Uh
chissà
ormai inizio a sparargli anche su un
culo c'è tanto Oh chi cazzo sei da dove
spunta la gente ogni tanto non capisco
intanto qualcuno esce fuori dal nulla io
non so come Ah qua c'è Ah c'è una barca
qua Bella uh Salve uh uh così via cioè
sono un ospite io Eh ma che cazzo
Ahia io entrerei
tenetela tu sta bomba Madonna esplosa
non è morta Beh per caso
Ragazzi sto andando un po' a corto di
colpi effettivamente Secondo me devo
risparmiarmi un pochettino perché a
furia di sparare a tutti quanti
ok Quella è una porta chiusa perché c'è
un simbolo posso salire di qua che c'è
quella che lancia le bombe da un'ora e
mezza
grazie eh No veramente
Oh attenta che non accendere che qua è
un casino Mamma grazie zia Proietti Oh
menomale dopo di Proietti Oh per i Nice
abbiamo finito di fare casino qua
Ok questo che cacchio è un simbolo
stranissimo però devo utilizzare la
chiave con quel simbolo ma prima che la
trovi Cioè Passerà una vita in mezzo Chi
è che continua a lanciare bombe avete
rotto il cazzo avete rotto il cazzo
tutti quanti Pam sa che è morto anche
lui non è morto
adesso è morto non è morto
Minchia quelli mutati ragazzi sono
incredibili fanno veramente schifo bene
Un sacco di lago Siamo arrivati al lago
Siamo arrivati
oh pesce ma sono io pazzo sento qualcuno
che sbatte le porte di qua poi ste
chiavi Attenzione che c'è una bomba Eh
la sento
Eccola ok Vabbè era abbastanza
visibile Ok che poi non so come non si
fa niente ma anche a sta distanza
Secondo me una bomba del genere
sto casino qua avete rotto un'ora che
non sto chiedendo incredibile che lì non
pensa le stesse identiche cose abbiamo
un cervello in due Lion si orgoglioso di
questo molti mi descrivono come
intelligente altrimenti
Ma la vogliamo smettere di far casino
per cortesia mi ha visto peccato che
anche meno Comunque fratello poi fai tu
Questo è un mutante mutato No è morto e
basta Grazie delle bozze che stavi
tirando senza un motivo A meno che non
ci sia qualcuno di nascosto qualcuno
ci ha messo un'ora e un'ora di dire di
casino e Lion l'ha tirata fuori in 3
secondi sei stupido proprio cosa stai
facendo questo qua dove volevo andare
cos'è cos'è che posto è Oh minchia la
usiamo sta torcia finalmente un'ora e
mezza nel buio finalmente Meno male
allora non la do accendere io no perché
ero in dubbio
ha fratello che è
chi cazzo è io non lo farei con leggere
Oh my brother Come si chiama questo qua
Carlos sembrava che non vedessi l'ora di
parlare mi piace il Signore dimmi hai
una sigaretta la prima cosa che ti viene
dopo essere stato liberato da un sacco e
la Ce l'hai una sigaretta Va bene va
bene Pedro Come cazzo ti chiami non ti
muovere sempre il dio
bene morto finita minchia
chi cazzo è quello non me lo ricordo
proprio
ti manca un occhio frate Non so se te ne
sei accorto attento
Minchia mi vuole No Me l'hai iniettato
cazzo
capito termina e quindi e quindi ragazzi
finisce qui il primo episodio di
Resident Evil Oh no Cash strangerman
Smettila di fare il Mercante mi piaceva
il Mercante Ok ma ci vediamo stasera
avete capito bene perché stasera uscirà
un altro episodio due in un giorno
Incredibile No non solo i Gameplay
tornati a casa due in un giorno incremai
successo quei ragazzi Preparatevi perché
alle 18 uscirà il secondo Gameplay con
il proseguimento della storia quindi non
vi preoccupate che sto Resident Evil lo
finiamo tutto e nella maniera migliore
del mondo perché mi sta piacendo
tantissimo e spero anche a voi
iscrivetevi al canale lasciato un bel mi
piace e fatemi sapere nei commenti Cosa
ne pensate E noi come sempre ci vediamo
dove cazzo è il telecomando ad un
prossimo video Beh ragazzi